[Música]
ah
11 departamentos colombianos fueron
víctimas de un paro armado decretado por
el grupo delincuencial el clan del golfo
esta organización está vinculada a
múltiples hechos de violencia también al
narcotráfico y llevó a cabo este paro a
raíz de la extradición a eeuu de su
máximo líder darío antonio úsuga alias
otoniel según las cifras de la
jurisdicción especial para la paz la gp
el impacto del paro deja 24 civiles
muertos 2 integrantes de la fuerza
pública también fallecidos 26 vías
bloqueadas y 138 comunidades confinadas
22 ataques a la fuerza pública también
fueron registrados son cifras muy
diferentes las que registra el
ministerio de defensa que reportó
solamente 6 muertos entre civiles
policías y soldados el paro entorpeció
el abastecimiento también la movilidad
interregional y cerca de un centenar de
vehículos también fueron incinerados si
miramos reportes de paros armados
ilegales llevados a cabo en el pasado
por diferentes grupos ilegales ninguno
había tenido el nivel de violencia ni la
simultaneidad en tantas regiones como el
que llevó a cabo recientemente plan del
golfo este episodio de violencia que
vivió colombia deja en evidencia
nuevamente que no es algo nuevo es casi
reiterativo en ese país y deja también
en evidencia la falta de presencia del
estado colombiano para garantizar un
aspecto básico de la constitución que es
la seguridad de sus ciudadanos 11 de los
32 departamentos de ese país de cerca de
50 millones de habitantes estuvieron
bloqueados por este grupo delincuencial
mientras el presidente iván duque estaba
en costa rica en la posición del nuevo
presidente rodrigo chávez se normalizó
definitivamente la violencia o este tipo
de actos en colombia el estado es
incapaz de hacer presencia en esas
regiones más apartadas donde están las
fuerzas armadas colombianas para
defender la soberanía y también
garantizar la seguridad de los
ciudadanos lo mejor que pudo hacer el
ministro de defensa diego molano fue
ofrecer una recompensa de 1,2 millones
de dólares por el paradero de los
presuntos sucesores de alias otoniel por
eso hoy en el debate de france 24
hablamos de la ausencia de la presencia
del estado colombiano un mal ya casi
crónico para esa nación suramericana y
las consecuencias que esto para
consolidar la paz en ese país y también
el progreso de las regiones para
analizar este tema saludamos en el
estudio de france 24 a maría josé
pizarro ella es senadora electa
recientemente por el pacto histórico y
también está con nosotros eduard
rodríguez él es representante de la
cámara en el congreso de colombia por el
partido centro democrático ustedes
también nuestros televidentes pueden
participar en este debate pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos por supuesto
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas en
torno a este tema pues le doy la
bienvenida a nuestros invitados en el
estudio esto es un privilegio que nos da
después de la pandemia ya volver a tener
invitados al canal de estudio de france
24 a los dos les agradezco por estar con
nosotros y yo quiero maríajosé comenzar
con usted para
en compañía de eduardo hacer una
explicación para las personas que están
fuera de las fronteras colombianas
explicar como punto de partida del
debate que es un paro armado porque en
colombia se ve todo el tiempo en las
noticias o eso es algo que los
colombianos han venido viendo a lo largo
de los años pero para la gente que está
fuera del contexto del conflicto
colombiano no es muy claro que es un
paro armado pues bueno lo primero es que
desearíamos no ver nunca ni haber
naturalizado en nuestro país ningún tipo
de acción armada ni mucho menos un paro
que es el control territorial por parte
de un grupo armado de la ley a que
sigamos a la población civil hay
diferentes medidas o diferentes
digamos acciones que han tomado los
grupos armados al margen de la ley a lo
largo de la historia en sus paros
armados pero ésta en concreto implicaba
la prohibición por parte de estos grupos
de que algún ningún comercio podría
estar abierto no podía haber nadie
transitando por las calles es decir
cualquier comercio que estuviera abierto
es inmediatamente tendría una
consecuencia y esto iniciado pues
obviamente el asesinato de el dueño del
comercio había control por parte de los
grupos armados que estaban vigilando las
calles las avenidas de estos territorios
evitando cualquier tipo de tránsito es
decir todo el mundo en sus casas
guardado no queremos ver a nadie en las
calles o pena de que pueda haber alguna
acción armada en su contra y esto es
básicamente
un paro armado establecido durante unos
días en concreto y generalmente pues
anuncian una causa válida uno
definitivamente es en respuesta a lo que
ellos consideren pues digamos está
sucediendo en el país este pues creo que
sí es uno de los mayores los de mayor
connotación se hemos vivido por el
control tan amplio el gran número de
departamentos y de municipios que
estuvieron esos días bajo el control no
de las fuerzas de seguridad del estado
clark sino de los grupos armados
ilegales eduard para completar este
punto de partida del debate algo más que
decir ya tenemos aquí una explicación un
poco más clara pero a lo largo de la
historia colombia ha visto varios para
usar y antes de este hubo también uno
por parte de la guerrilla de ln en el
departamento de arauca que es fronterizo
con venezuela en el nororiente del país
digamos que lo que ha hecho la guerrilla
y los grupos armados al margen de la ley
es tratar de incidir en la población
civil en lo que ellos han llamado paros
armados que entre comillas es no salen
no van a ninguna parte no hay transporte
y ahí empieza a generar una prueba a lo
que el estado de derecho o las fuerzas
militares tienen que hacer que es
proteger a toda la ciudadanía usualmente
ellos lo hacen lo hacen para el
cumpleaños de ln en arauca en el
catatumbo en algunos sectores de choco y
por supuesto en el sur del país
en este caso el clan del golfo que es
una organización para los que nos están
viendo armada al margen de la ley que se
surte del narcotráfico yo diría que es
la combinación entre guerrilla y
paramilitares que se unieron y se
vincularon para quedarse con las rutas
del narcotráfico que vos proceso de paz
no se entregaron estas organizaciones
criminales quieren incidir y de hecho
inciden en algunos sectores del país
el más duro golpe que se le ha dado a
estas organizaciones es la captura de
otoniel otoniel para los que nos están
viendo sólo es comparable con pablo
escobar gaviria un narcotraficante de la
misma índole que generaba miedo para
generar pánico que tenía un cartel pero
en este caso en otro nivel también
estaba escondido en las montañas de
antioquia donde no se dejaba ver pero
digamos que su brazo armado contaba
líderes políticos organizaciones
militares y una serie de
de institucionalidad cuando se le da a
este grupo este el gran golpe y no
solamente a él sino toda la estructura
criminal por supuesto que quedan algunos
residuos de esos residuos trataron de
incidir en este caso generando miedo y
el estado a través de sus ministros el
ministro del interior y el ministro de
la defensa
e igualmente a través de toda la
institucionalidad y toda la fuerza
pública hicieron presencia no obstante
una sola un solo hecho de violencia que
asesinen dos militares no importa la
cifra es una sola vida y eso ya tiene
que atemorizar nuestra genera pánico en
la región edward hago la ronda a la
inversa para para cambiar la dinámica
la pregunta clave de este programa es
porque se mantiene la ausencia del
estado colombiano en esas regiones
porque los colombianos de esas regiones
que este por ejemplo menciona el
catatumbo el departamento de chocó
algunas zonas como arauca prácticamente
se han acostumbrado a vivir sin la
presencia del estado colombiano no
solamente la presencia de militares o de
la fuerza pública sino también de la
falta de escuela la falta de carreteras
la falta de hospitales de
infraestructura en esas regiones
puntuales que da paso a estos medios
déjeme contarle un poco la cronología de
lo que ha venido ocurriendo en colombia
durante los últimos años en el 2002
cerca de 700 22 municipios están
cooptados por las organizaciones
criminales llamadas farc ln o grupos
paramilitares
hubo un plan que se llamó el plan
colombia ese plan colombia tenía que
generar una injerencia en estos
territorios olvidados una vez la fuerza
pública lo recuperar allá los concejales
o los diputados y más
importante esta cronología porque eso se
transformó y empieza a generar una
transformación que está pasando
actualmente digamos que ya hay
infraestructura vial digamos que ya hay
jueces que ya todos los alcaldes en este
país despachan no obstante como el
narcotráfico es un negocio tan rentable
ya no decidieron digamos que pelear sino
poner incluso alcaldes cooptar a las
miembros de la fuerza pública a través
de mecanismos de corrupción y de esa
manera que los dejen traficar es una
guerra que hemos dado y tiene que es una
guerra institucional ese es el problema
ahora también está ahondando en un
problema cultural y es que nuestros
adolescentes niños también dicen hombre
yo no quiero ser ingeniero no quiero ser
médico no quiero ser austronauta si no
quiero ser narcotraficante y lass
desafortunadamente en algunos sectores
del país dicen yo quiero ser la esposa
de ese narcotraficante que es un tema
una realidad social que hay que romper y
que está arraigada en algunos sectores
precisamente eso deja en evidencia la
falta de oportunidades y también esa
falta de fortaleza del estado cuando un
funcionario estatal pasa a ser miembro o
colaborador de estos grupos
delincuenciales hay fisuras que opina
varias o por este lado nada yo creo que
ningún joven en este país y nadie que
tenga
digamos un mínimo de estructura y que
haya podido acceder a la educación a un
entorno amoroso a un entorno tranquilo a
un entorno seguro pues decide ser un
matón yo creo que hay eso es llevado a
la gente precisamente por la falta de
oportunidades yo tampoco considero que
sea hoy que vemos esa alianza entre los
poderes locales y los poderes y los
grupos armados ilegales en nuestro país
es una tragedia histórica en colombia
pero en este país las estructuras
armadas y el narcotráfico han venido
cooptando las instancias del poder y
esto es algo que por supuesto tenemos
que que erradicar de la vida política y
de la vida social de nuestro país pero
no lo podemos lograr
primero porque seguimos siendo el modelo
de lucha contra las drogas en colombia
es un modelo absolutamente fracasado por
mucho que no lo digamos desde el plan
colombia si el plan colombia hubiese
funcionado hoy tendríamos un país que
caminaría hacia otro con la inversión de
recursos inmensa que se ha hecho en el
marco o que se hizo en el marco del plan
colombia definitivamente hoy tenemos una
lucha contra las drogas fracasada es un
gran negocio es un gran negro con lo que
hoy ya son casi que unas multinacionales
del narcotráfico porque efectivamente
tenemos por ejemplo el clan de sinaloa
operando en nuestro territorio tenemos
una convivencia entre poderes locales
entre muchas veces en algunos casos
tristemente para tragedia y la historia
colombiana en algunos casos comiéndose
de la fuerza pública pero también como
bien no lo decían entre grupos armadas
drive y en medio de todo eso tenemos una
sociedad civil que ha tenido que
aprender a sobrevivir en medio de la
violencia y hay dos formas de sobre ir o
aprendes a sobrevivir en el territorio o
te desplazas hacia las grandes ciudades
y vives en la miseria esa es la tragedia
la realidad colombiana y es la que
tenemos que erradicar en nuestro país
pero hemos puesto que es como te digo ha
estado históricamente por lo menos en la
historia contemporánea en nuestro país y
a pesar de los esfuerzos hoy no es una
realidad que haya podido erradicarse de
la vida política y social con 11
dejemos sobre la mesa variamos el tema
de la lucha contra las drogas que ya lo
vamos a tocar más adelante edward yo
creo que usted es bueno con el contexto
hay algo que llama la atención del caso
colombiano y es que aquí se está
repitiendo un ciclo hace algunos años el
personaje en el mundo del narcotráfico
era pablo escobar una vez sale pablo
escobar de la escena las farc y lln
toman un poco más de fuerza y los
paramilitares salen de escena luego
entonces llegan estos grupos que eran
pequeños que se reagruparon en muchos
casos a retomar esas rutas del
narcotráfico y armar estos grandes como
maria jose lo explica vemos que tienen
es como un pulpo que tiene ya varios
brazos en ecuador paraguay méxico y
otros países de centroamérica que falla
en la institucionalidad colombiana que
este tipo de ciclo se repite vuelve y
surge en la historia del país un grupo
que domina el narcotráfico afecta a la
seguridad del país pone en jaque a la
ciudadanía y afecta al desarrollo de las
regiones yo creo que con tristeza tengo
que decirlo pero si hay que replantear
la lucha contra el narcotráfico eso es
un debate que hay que abrirlo
transparentemente pero no desde el
contexto colombiano solamente sino el
contexto internacional uno se le
preguntaría a los países como francia
españa y eeuu donde consumen la droga y
donde cuesta más aquí un kilo de cocaína
cuesta entre 1 a 4 millones de pesos
allá llega hasta 10 12 millones de
dólares y eso hay que replantearlo
porque es que eso que ellos se consumen
es lo que mata niños es lo que asesina
mujeres es lo que genera violencia en
las regiones y es lo que está atacando
toda una institucionalidad y una
estructura que por ser tan rentable nos
ha sido muy difícil salir aquí se ha
hecho algunos planteamientos muy serios
sobre la erradicación de cultivos
ilícitos y la transformación de hecho en
el proceso con las farc se hizo un gran
de una gran apuesta en regiones muy
apartadas que se han cumplido donde se
han ser donde se han entregado cerca de
10 billones de dólares que son casi 40
millones de pesos de aquí pues recursos
colombianos a esos a esas regiones sin
embargo lo que vemos en muchas regiones
es que es más rentable el narcotráfico
que dicen bueno yo paso aquí siembro
yuca pero más arriba siembro la mata de
coca a fin de que podamos continuar con
el negocio y yo sí creo que ese debate
se tiene que dar a nivel mundial porque
queramos o no yo sí tengo que decírselo
a la comunidad internacional nosotros
como colombianos somos las víctimas
somos los que somos el resultado de
asesinar soldados policías
niños políticos que son decentes y que
quieren trabajar en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico entonces hay que dar el
debate y hay que replantear toda esta
lucha contra el narcotráfico entonces
aquí entre los dos entre ustedes dos
como invitados del programa que se pueda
hacer entonces para replantear esa lucha
antidrogas olvidémonos de eeuu que es un
país que tiene una idea muy firme de
cómo tiene que ser esa lucha antidrogas
es muy difícil que a washington
modifique un poco esa esa lucha así lo
ha demostrado por lo menos las últimas
administraciones y los últimos gobiernos
allí como puede entonces colombia
replantear una lucha antidrogas distinta
por lo menos para el problema interno
maríajosé
pues mira así como el debate ambiental
hoy es un debate mundial pues
precisamente sucede con otros problemas
que tenemos en el planeta por ejemplo
el problema nuclear del mundo es un
problema y es un debate mundial es un
debate de uno o de otro país con
responsabilidades por supuesto en
quiénes son y tienen grandes arsenales
nucleares o quienes están emitiendo más
o quiénes emiten más gases
invernadero etcétera en sus países es
decir asumen mayores responsabilidades
en el caso de los países productores que
no solamente colombia hay otro tipo de
estupefacientes que se producen en otros
lugares del mundo y que además
convivimos con la misma realidad nos
quedamos con la violencia nos quedamos
con los muertos nos quedamos sin la
capacidad del estado de poder
digamos ocupar los territorios que han
venido ocupando por supuesto porque de
eso viven los grupos al margen de la ley
que están traficando de drogas en
nuestro país sin la posibilidad de
controlar porque ellos controlan el
territorio y con base en ese control
territorial pues por supuesto es que el
negocio se puede dar digamos de manera
tranquila tenemos que entenderlo es un
negocio y el dinero no se queda aquí en
colonia y así como nosotros tenemos un
problema como productores problemas hay
otros países que tienen el problema de
que son atrás son países de tránsito por
donde pasa la droga hacia sus países
ricos países centroamericanos como tú lo
dices lo mismo sucede en algunos países
de oriente medio precisamente con la
producción de opio etcétera frank y pero
pero tiene que hacer un debate entendido
de esa manera por supuesto que a veces
el mundo no está listo para dar el
debate pero nosotros tenemos la
responsabilidad de poner las alertas
ahora más allá de eso tenemos que
encontrar mecanismos por lo menos
regionales para poder empezar a mitigar
el problema tenemos un diálogo pendiente
con méxico por ejemplo porque
precisamente hoy como te lo decía pero
pero colombia con toda esta situación
porque esta lucha no es de ayer esto
lleva a muchas de ellas y colombiano
lidera en eso colombiano
nacional sí porque los gobiernos
colombianos se han doblegado en mi
criterio a la política internacional de
lucha contra las drogas decir aquella
que se nos impone de eeuu o se nos
impone desde el exterior pero nosotros
no hemos planteado con seriedad el
problema nosotros no vemos
planteada por no ha sido un
planteamiento eficiente que realmente
permita que nosotros también tengamos
mucho que decir frente al modelo que se
nos ha impuesto y que definitivamente ha
servido en muchos casos para alimentar y
te digo para mí el tema de la paz es
esencial vamos a mencionar también hay
que mencionar aquí el tema de la
corrupción
colombiano pues
también los actores armados exacto y con
los poderes locales vuelvo vuelvo al
tema de este paro y lo que representa lo
que representó este paro armado del clan
del golfo bloqueo ya lo decíamos 11
departamentos incluso una capital
departamental la ciudad de montería que
es una ciudad intermedia en colombia
tuvieron que cerrar el comercio las
escuelas y las universidades y la ciudad
estuvo prácticamente aislada del resto
del país
de transporte aéreo terrestre y
comercial por por este paro cuál es el
alcance de eduard que evidencia este
paro que claramente no es no tiene el
alcance que tuvieron los otros este fue
mayor esto qué alarmas despierta para el
estado colombiano y bueno para el país
entero el alcance que tuvo el plan del
golfo con este para yo creo que uno
tiene que reconocer cuando las cosas
digamos salen mal y sale mal porque esto
no depende solamente del gobierno
nacional hay unos actores locales que
tienen que de una u otra forma ejercer
la autoridad y bien una palabra que me
llega a mi corazón y mi mente y es la
confianza institucional porque esos
ciudadanos de montería de sucre tuvieron
miedo y cuál fue la respuesta que le dio
tanto el gobierno nacional como los
gobiernos locales a esos ciudadanos que
tuvieron mía porque pues quien no va a
tener miedo de que dice si usted abre a
las 7 de la noche le vamos a quemar su
negocio
evito el problema y voy y aquí viene un
tema también de
algo que yo le llamo cobardía de los
grupos armados al margen de la ley
porque precisamente estos actos
terroristas no se cometen propiamente en
la ciudad capital como se evidenció sino
como lo vemos en las imágenes en las
laderas muy lejanas de donde él
los miembros de la fuerza pública no
llegan entonces ellos lo que hacen y lo
han hecho en arauca como lo hicieron
esta vez en el en el en el planes en el
portón en antioquia en el córdoba es
atacar
jurisdicciones donde no está la fuerza
pública entran atacan asesinan a alguien
que va pasando o queman un bus o atacan
la caravana donde va la policía y se
repliegan y se desaparece entonces
digamos que esa esa
orquestada
por qué estado plan criminal pues
también tiene que darse en el contexto
de entender que no es la heladera es que
lo hacen recíprocamente pero que sí
causan miedo y causan temor y es un tema
también de la fuerza pública de
responder inmediatamente se ha atacado
sea
pues no solamente al final pero es que
once departamentos estuvieron bloqueados
y eso no le dice nada al gobierno
nacional pero por supuesto que si el
gobierno
sí lo ha dado y lo dio con toda la
contundencia trabajando de la mano de
alcaldes locales y estos pero también
hay que poner las cosas por su nombre y
poner por las cosas por su nombre es que
usted tiene una cantidad de kilómetros
cien doscientos kilómetros y pues lo que
está fallando claramente es la
inteligencia porque se debería actuar
rápidamente en donde posiblemente pueden
afectar nuestras organizaciones
criminales y tratar de ir al donde están
atacando es un problema muy complejo
pero también hay que poner los temas en
contexto uno el miedo 2 la respuesta del
gobierno y 3 las difíciles
circunstancias
geológicas que nosotros tenemos para que
vayamos de su opinión sobre este tema
que le dice esto al gobierno saliente
del presidente saliente de bando que
pues bueno yo sí tengo que actuar con
todo mi sentido crítico además es mi
deber como congresista colombiano
colombiano en primer lugar tenemos una
política de seguridad y esto lo
demuestra lo que acaba de suceder en
este en este paro armado y es innegable
si no no habríamos tenido el control
territorial de un grupo armado al margen
de la ley en 11 departamentos de nuestro
país así de sencillo por mucho que
queramos maquillar lo poner bonito esta
es una realidad y yo quiero plantear un
digamos un paralelo que sucede en medio
de las movilizaciones y el estallido
social que vivimos el año pasado y que
las imágenes dieron vuelta por el mundo
entero vimos una fuerza pública que
ocupaba y estaba en todos los
territorios de este país que era muy
eficaz para el controlar a la población
civil que se estaba manifestando pero en
cambio fue absolutamente incapaz con
todo el poderío militar siendo uno de
los ejércitos más grandes de américa
latina- de controlar este grupo al
margen de la ley y de garantizarle a los
a los ciudadanos seguridad y por lo
tanto la ausencia del miedo sí pero que
se vio que estaban casi que acantonadas
en las estaciones o en los cuarteles
militares sin estar efectivamente
haciendo presencia a nivel territorial
en frente y ese poder a nivel
territorial a mí eso sí me parece
digamos no solamente un pésimo mensaje
sino la estocada final a la política de
seguridad de este gobierno y lo repito
el paralelo es dramático es dramático la
política de seguridad edward es una
política que viene de varios gobiernos
atrás tal vez esta fórmula esta
estrategia ya está un poco desgastada
para el contexto en el que está colombia
será momento para que el próximo
presidente que llegue plantee una nueva
política de acción ahora ya mí a mí me
parecería muy interesante que tanto
gustavo petro como federico gutiérrez
plantearon una política un esquema de
seguridad los que hemos estudiado el
tema lo sabemos que una fuerza pública
que no esté motivado que no esté
constantemente trabajando va a ser una
fuerza pública que no genera resultados
los éxitos contra las farc fue porque
estaban en operabilidad no quiero
escuchar pero durante el 2012 al 2018 la
fuerza pública se quedó cruzada de manos
absolutamente nada y por eso yo creo que
también hay que cuando llegamos al
gobierno de hecho encontramos una fuerza
pública temerosa miedosa y lo que tú
decías manejos en los cuarteles los
generales bebiendo whisky y nos tocó
volver a tomar esa política del 2002 de
decirles señores ustedes tienen que
estar en terreno no obstante miles de
hombres de la fuerza pública hoy están
en terreno están trabajando y están
atacando estas organizaciones criminales
prueba de ello es que pese a toda la
corrupción que hay en estos sectores y
en estas regiones apartadas donde
otoniel tenía alcaldes comprados
políticos comprados y tenía también a
los militares comprados nuestra fuerza
pública llegó hasta el último rincón y
capturó auto ni el como siguiera
capturando a chiquito malo ya todos los
bandidos que se enfrenten al estado yo
creo que lo que sí hay que unirnos como
país es a enfrentar a estos criminales
que generan miedo en estas regiones
justamente juan paper que es un
investigador de human rigth watch habla
de esa estrategia él dice que el
gobierno colombiano tiene una política
de seguridad que parte de un diagnóstico
errado
porque cree que basta con capturar a las
cabecillas para desmantelar estos grupos
armados yo creo que ahí entra en este
rompecabezas lo que les preguntaba hace
unos minutos y es que a lo largo de los
años vuelven y surgen estas figuras
grandes o estos grupos delincuenciales
que vuelven y toman fuerza por lo que
esto defendería un poco esta hipótesis
de the human right watch como lo ve
usted maria jose pues mira si algo nos
ha enseñado la historia en nuestro país
donde la paz y la guerra han convivido
de manera trágica no es precisamente que
cada vez que un proceso de paz fracasó
en colombia volvemos a unos ciclos no
solamente interminables de la guerra
sino cada vez más degradados de la
guerra en colombia cada vez es más
degradado cada vez es más difícil
encontrar una estructura realmente a la
cual combatir tenemos que hacer una
confederación de grupos armados que
conviven que se disputan el territorio
no solamente la ruta pues por supuesto
las rutas pero también a nivel
territorial el control territorial esa
es digamos la constante desde el primer
acuerdo de paz exitoso en 1990
esa es la esa es la realidad los años
más cruentos de la guerra en colombia
los vivimos precisamente después de ese
acuerdo de paz y veníamos yo no creo que
algunos militares aburridos en los
cuarteles tomando whisky si no veníamos
en un proceso de paz por supuesto que
las fuerzas armadas tenían que
repensarse para un nuevo contexto atrás
y cuando fracasa el proceso de paz pues
hoy estamos ante una realidad la primera
una realidad de violencia como no se
vivía desde hace muchísimos años en este
país
hoy estamos casi que retornando a los
índices de violencia de antes de la
firma del acuerdo de paz es decir de
esos de esas épocas más duras y
degradadas de la guerra en nuestro país
sino que además estamos viendo uno de
los procesos electorales más complejos y
más inseguros en la historia de colombia
y yo creo que sí tiene que ser un
momento para parar y pensar sobre el
rumbo de nuestro país queremos una
colombia en paz pues por supuesto que
todos tendremos que repensar nos para
una clara bien paz el hecho de que se
capture otoniel no significa que esta
alianza entre poderes local
y alcaldes gobernadores como tú quieras
y
el cabecilla desaparezca no se reinventa
porque esa es la tragedia del
paramilitarismo el yo para el registro
de todo digamos de toda esa connivencia
complementarle si me lo permite maría
josé que algo que es muy importante y es
que esto no es solamente local estos son
organizaciones transnacionales muy bien
infiltradas con unas financiaciones y un
paralelo lo que significa que tiene que
ir en un contexto internacional a
trabajar entre los diferentes gobiernos
o bien sea para legalizar
y esto de pronto me puede costar porque
pero el país es que decir las cosas por
su nombre y no es un debate que puede
quedar sobre la mesa en cualquier
momento bien para seguir atacando como
se ha venido haciendo durante los tres
últimos 30 años de vida yo tengo 40 años
y siempre he visto narcotráfico
narcotraficante es violencia y si hay
que terminar el ciclo y hay que
replantearnos nosotros las nuevas
generaciones como decir venga está
pasando algo y tenemos que generar
soluciones una de esas soluciones que
hay que trabajar y ojalá los próximos
candidatos lo tengan es un trabajo
enfocado en esas regiones entre otras
porque en nuestros jóvenes están
convirtiéndose perdón la expresión en
los futuros otoniel del país y es por
una clara presencia ausencia de política
pública donde los próximos candidatos
tendrán que hablar de la jornada única
empezando desde ahí para protegerlos y
alejarlos de esas organizaciones
criminales que los captan que les
entregan un millón de pesos luego los
ponen
a hacer o a contar si bien el ejército o
no luego les dan un arma luego los
convierten porque todo eso es un ciclo
donde nuestros jóvenes los estamos
perdiendo a los 28 años y eso es como
consecuencia del narcotráfico y como
consecuencia que no hemos tomado la
decisión como país de tomar el toro por
los cachos y decirle venga aquí tenemos
una problemática que si seguimos dándole
largas no va a pasar absolutamente nada
y no es solamente el tema de la
violencia también la ausencia del estado
es igual a la carencia de
garantía de los derechos fundamentales
de los ciudadanos y de la
institucionalidad entonces esto se
vuelve un círculo vicioso que no
solamente lleva a que la gente termine
me dice usted lo pone en el contexto
internacional hablando yo soy
ambientalista hemos hecho las
principales leyes ambientales pero la
mayor causa de deforestación es
propiamente el narcotráfico la sed es un
tema transversal que no solamente nos
incumbe ya a nosotros sino que le tiene
que cumplir todo le tiene que abrir los
ojos al mundo como bien lo decía maria
jose plazo no puede ser un tema de un
gobierno sino de una política de estado
estado me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa
quiero preguntarles precisamente por las
propuestas
que hacen los candidatos de cara a las
presidenciales que están por realizarse
por lo menos la primera vuelta en ese
país en los próximos días que proponen
que hay de nuevo en estas propuestas de
los candidatos que
ofrezcan un panorama distinto para esta
lucha antidrogas para esta lucha contra
estos grupos delincuenciales y hacia la
presencia del estado que ese es el tema
central de esto que garantice la
presencia colombiano en las regiones
bueno lo primero es combatir el problema
el principal problema que hay en nuestro
país que es la desigualdad y si no
planteamos soluciones a la desigualdad
en nuestro país es muy difícil que
podamos salir adelante eso es y hay aquí
si hay todo tipo de propuestas una
política integral enfocada hacia las
mujeres que hoy soy el eslabón más débil
digamos de todas las cadenas de
violencia somos nosotras las que paramos
los hijos para la guerra y por supuesto
tiene que haber una política seria para
nosotras por supuesto que tenemos que
enfocarnos en un modelo de seguridad
distinto nosotros hemos propuesto un
modelo de seguridad humana que además lo
hemos discutido bastante en el congreso
de la república precisamente porque el
modelo de seguridad democrática está
fracasado y por lo tanto tenemos que
pensar no es un modelo de seguridad y
eso implica no solamente la propuesta
desde el gobierno nacional sino también
cómo se va a dialogar implementar con
distintos actores políticos y sociales
de nuestro país e implica educación
pública gratuita de calidad implica gps
efectivamente pasar digamos de una sola
matriz de a diversificar nuestra
producción a entregarle la tierra
también a los campesinos es uno de los
problemas históricos de colombia ha sido
las fracasadas las ganarla el que no se
haya hecho nunca una reforma agraria de
nuestro país y por supuesto tenemos que
retornar a nuestra educación campesina y
esto implica no solamente en términos de
soberanía alimentaria sino de garantizar
que la gerencia de la tierra pueda estar
no solamente en el 1% de la población
sino que las mayorías sociales puedan
acceder a la tierra y puedan acceder a
todos los servicios del estado implica
la paz total
y la paz integral y yo creo que si no
nos enfocamos en todo esto nos vamos a
quedar como siempre con un monstruo de
mil cabezas que cada vez es más difícil
de control que por este lado de edward
yo creo que son tres
rutas esenciales primero la ruta de la
seguridad donde tiene que estar primero
la prevención cuidar a nuestros niños
niñas adolescentes su implica darle
oportunidades a todos los niños no
solamente hasta el bachillerato sino
hasta la educación superior donde yo soy
autor de la educación gratuita para
estratos 1 2 y 3 y el candidato federico
gutiérrez propone un millón de becas que
creo que tienen que ser en nuevas
tecnologías y es una ruta completa donde
en los lugares más apartados donde no
hay institucionalidad y donde el
narcotráfico tiene mayor incidencia lo
segundo el crecimiento económico para
todos con igualdad de condiciones
protegiendo la libertad de empresa y el
tercer alimento que yo le llamaba
justicia social con oportunidades para
todos los colombianos justicia social
implica que el que la haga la pague que
exista una verdadera red socialización
cuando entren en un proceso de
encarcelamiento para que trabajen y
estudien y oportunidades que significa
que todo eso tiene que tener una
trazabilidad y es que si no abrimos los
caminos para que todos los colombianos
entendamos que somos absolutamente
iguales en derechos
en obligaciones no podemos llegar a un
estado donde nos respetemos mutuamente y
eso también está en un algo muy pequeño
para culminar y es en reconocer también
lo que hemos ganado como estado como
hemos venido avanzando y hacia dónde
vamos yo creo que hay que mirar no
solamente con un tema que hoy el país
está súper dividido sino con un tema de
enfoque de colombia de 2050 2100
inclusive una ruta determinada hacia el
futuro me queda un minuto para finalizar
el programa 'el quiero que hagamos
conclusiones rápidamente lo que deja
este tema este paro la ausencia del
estado los temas que ustedes han tocado
los diferentes puntos de vista comienza
entonces con edward para hacer la ronda
la inversa y cerró con maria jose edward
no yo diría que nosotros hoy tenemos un
país que ha crecido en infraestructura
que ha crecido en oportunidades con la
economía creciendo al 10 6 por ciento
este trimestre crecemos crecimos cerca
del 86 por ciento no obstante es el
crecimiento tiene que llegar ese empleo
a formalización y oportunidades para
todos los colombianos creo que lo que
nos muestra todo este tema del clan del
golfo es que hoy tenemos primero que
poner los puntos sobre las íes y eso es
el debate abierto democrático que no
solamente en el contexto nacional sino
internacional sobre la legalización o no
de la droga y segundo hacer una política
social tan fuerte tan sólida que ayude a
transformar y ayudarle a oportunidades
en las regiones más apartadas a todos
los colombianos gracias al bar maria
jose rápidamente para el cierre lo que
colombia requiere y está pidiendo a
gritos las juventudes no solamente un
país para ellas sino además un cambio
profundo pero un cambio sería en un
cambio tranquilo un cambio
definitivamente la gente está pidiendo
un cambio y lo que la gente nos está
pidiendo es poder tener y habitar en
este país no solamente la paz la
seguridad también la educación también
son las oportunidades no es solamente
crecer un poco
no solamente alcanzar lo que lo que
retrocedimos en medio de la pandemia
sino avanzar muchísimo más para eso para
lograr todo lo que nos hemos propuesto
este país necesita transitar hacia la
paz en medio de la guerra en medio del
dolor de los colombianos y de las
colombianas va a ser muy difícil
reconstruir y sacar adelante este pan
jose maria jose ya eduard les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
programa el debate de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas todo esto
tendrá un nuevo rumbo a partir de el 29
de mayo cuando colombia elija al nuevo
presidente por lo menos se ha llevado a
cabo la primera vuelta presidencial un
evento político que ustedes pueden ver
aquí a través de france 24 con todo el
cubrimiento especial que vamos a tener
ese día sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]